r c'est donc un coup de théâtre
judiciaire le procès en révision de
patrick dils est achevée hier par un
nouveau verdict de culpabilité contre
toute attente les jurés de la cour
d'assises dès mineurs de race l'ont
condamné au terme de six heures de
délibérations à 25 ans de réclusion la
stupéfaction de la défense après le
réquisitoire de l'avocat général qui
s'était lui prononcé pour l'acquittement
valérie rebute le huis clos est terminée
le public est autorisé entendre le
verdict
à la question patrick dils est il
coupable du meurtre d'alexandre et de
cyril
la réponse est oui à la majorité des
voix
la salle ne respire plus patrick dils
est figé ses proches totalement
abasourdi expliquez moi
cette décision je comprends pas peur je
comprends pas nous avons 4 comprennent
pas non plus qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ce serait même pas que je suis déçu
c'est que je ne comprends pas cette
décision qui n'a pas de sens at on vu
une cour d'assises condamné à 25 ans
quelqu'un qui en a déjà fait 15 plus
jeunes mineurs des pays membres du
conseil de l'europe
lorsqu'un parquet général devant de
l'aqip ans et le tout après révision de
la plus haute juridiction française
c'est totalement comprends c'est
incroyable procès où quelques heures
plus tôt l'avocat général demandé
l'acquittement pur et simple de patrick
10 6 heures de délibéré et un verdict en
forme de délivrance pour les parties
civiles
j'en étais sur les différents circuits
quelles habitudes et les petits garçons
c'était pas de la fantaisie
on avait un dossier qui se parler on
habitait certitude on a bd on avait des
conclusions qu'il avait faits terribles
dont je vous ai toujours dit qu'on
pouvait pas inventer quand on lui a
donné cette chance de s'expliquer devant
cette cour d'assises il ne s'est pas
expliqué il n'a pas donné d'explication
il n'a pas donné de raisons pour
lesquelles il avait passé tant d'aveux
jeu des descriptions ci précise des
meurtres qu'il avait connu le père de
patrick dils ou victime d'un malaise
quelques jours plus tôt n'a pas pu
assister au verdict seule madame deal se
repart alors que dans la nuit un convoi
toutes sirènes hurlantes ramène son fils
en prison sous les huées de ses
codétenus que si faute il patrick dils
où le verdict